while democrats continue to burn down
the country president trump has been
nominated
for the nobel peace prize not once but
twice
one of the president's nominators asked
this question can you name a person
who has done more for peace than
president trump while i am sitting
across the street from the white house
there is a major middle east peace deal
being signed today it's a wonderful
question
shows you the difference between anarchy
and rioting between
violence and peace we'll get into it i'm
michael knowles this michael knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday comes from john
who says at football games they should
say ladies and gentlemen please rise
for the playing of our national anthem
everyone else please kneel or remain
seated in honor of our president donald
trump
i love this idea because it backs the
left into a corner right and they have
to
either show some respect for the flag or
they have to
in a way show respect for the president
uh obviously john i think is joking but
he makes a great point
which is yesterday we were talking about
how the left backs conservatives into a
corner
so we're damned if we do and we're
damned if we don't they always do this
they're very good
at framing the political discussion
we've got to start doing that
as well and the left right now
is using violence and he's using the
threat of violence
to try to back us into this corner on
the election president trump while he's
being nominated for peace deals
uh he can't shoulder the entire burden
of the
conservative resistance to this on his
own we'll get into what that looks like
uh but first i gotta thank our friends
over at we the people holsters talk
about
making sure that you're in a safe
position we the people holsters
if you've got a handgun but you do not
have a good holster
you are just not doing firearms
correctly and we the people holsters
is the best these guys have terrific
designs first of all you know that i
lean a little bit more aesthetic even
beyond utility but they've also got
perfect utility
their their holsters are fitted
absolutely perfectly
for your firearm satisfaction guaranteed
best of all they start at just 39
3 9 unbelievable you got to make sure
that you are doing firearms correctly
also they're made right here in the usa
so to get started i've got an even
better deal for you
go to wethepeopleholsters.com knowles
get yours every holster ships free
comes with a lifetime guarantee and then
even though
the price was already so low you'll get
an additional 10
off with the offer code knowles so that
i'm no mathematical genius but that
brings it down
to 29 for an absolutely top shelf
holster
in an incredible design patriotic made
here in the usa go get it satisfaction
guaranteed if it's not a perfect fit you
can send it back you get a total refund
we the people holsters dot com slash
knowles and then what's the code very
easy to remember
knowles k w l e s go on over there
protect your firearm
today president trump speaking of
firearms and uh and violence and peace
president trump
has an historic peace deal that is being
signed
just today across the street which we'll
get into and for that reason
he is being nominated for the nobel
peace prize
now it seems a little confusing right
because you're talking about the threat
of violence
for peace this goes back to ronald
reagan it goes back far before ronald
reagan
the idea of peace through strength you
know during the previous administration
obama he was apologizing to everybody in
the world and giving things away to
everybody in the world and saying we're
not going to be violent what happens
the world gets much more violent because
of that trump comes and he says
we're going to be very strong we're
going to have a strong foreign policy
what happens
you get peace if you know anything about
geopolitics
that makes sense to you but for naive
people on the left it doesn't make sense
so why do you get nominated how do you
get nominated christian
tybring gide i'm certainly not
pronouncing that correctly a norwegian
parliamentarian
nominated trump for the nobel peace
prize
people have been using this as a punch
line but it's not a punch line
because donald trump certainly deserves
the peace prize
more than a previous recipient barack
obama
remember barack obama was nominated for
the nobel peace prize after having been
in office for nine days
it was completely ridiculous also
barack obama started a bunch of wars
remember that
they told me if i voted for john mccain
we'd get more wars in the middle east
well guess what happened i voted for
john mccain we got more wars in the
middle east
he was only nominated because he was a
symbol
of coming out of the bush eras and a
symbol of hope but his actual
policies were not very peaceful at all
what about al gore another past
recipient of the nobel peace prize
he got the prize for a powerpoint
presentation there was a bunch of bs
that there that that they actually had
to had the censor in british schools a
judge ruled that they had to censor
parts of it because they were just
factually ridiculous
he wins the peace prize donald trump why
should he get the peace prize uh because
he's signing historic peace deals
isn't that the point of the peace prize
you would think so he was nominated not
just once but twice another guy
magnus jacobson member of the swedish
parliament
uh also nominated trump uh because of
his peace deal not just
in israel but also a peace deal between
serbia and kosovo
when trump entered office and everyone
was predicting the worst and saying it
was going to be the worst president ever
i did say look we're all joking about
this now but watch trump is going to
bring peace to the middle east
well he sort of has so right actually at
my hotel
right now where i'm staying in dc i'm
here to do a few episodes of verdict
with
senator cruz at my hotel you have
delegations from israel you have
delegations from bahrain
you have delegations from all over
because directly across the street at
the white house
they're signing an historic peace deal
between israel and the
united arab emirates and israel and
bahrain
you're getting two new middle east peace
deals this is the first time in decades
that this has happened it's pretty
important stuff
so you've got those two deals but it's
not even just regarding israel
it we always joke about middle east
peace being the hardest thing to solve
right because
that area of the world has been at war
now for thousands and thousands of years
but that's not the only place that's at
war and it's not the only place that the
trump administration is working on peace
deals he's also gotten one
in kosovo and serbia for any of the 90s
kids
or people who were alive before then
you'll remember there was major violence
in kosovo in the late 1990s there have
always been these
sorts of tensions they've been simmering
for a long time trump also gets a deal
on that even democratic governor
gavin newsom is admitting that president
trump
is doing a good job this specifically on
the california wildfires
take a listen to newsome keeping praise
on trump
i want to thank you and acknowledge the
work that you've done
to be immediate in terms of your
response to our fmag request 14.
and we were just talking marculoducci's
ahead of the office of merged services
may be a record
that the states received in the f-mag
support
as well as the major disaster
declaration which you referenced
on august 22nd which was profoundly
significant
not only to help us support our mutual
aid system
but also individuals that are in
desperate need of support
we can agree to disagree and i
appreciate your frame on the politics of
this
but let me just acknowledge two things
briefly and i'll turn it back to you
there's no question when you look past
this
decade looking past almost a thousand
plus years
that we have not done justice on our
forest management i don't think anyone
disputes that
i want to acknowledge we have uh our u.s
forest representative here
the state of california your
administration just entered into
a first type commitment over the next 20
years
to double our vegetation management and
forest management
i want to thank you for supporting that
effort
you ever notice how all these democratic
psychos talk a big talk when they go on
cnn or msnbc
but then when they're face to face with
trump they have to admit he's doing a
pretty good job
you know there have been wildfires
raging throughout california and
and oregon and all over the place and
the left
broadly is blaming it on climate change
and trump's not doing enough on climate
change and you've got to hear what joe
biden's saying about this
which we'll get to in a second but gavin
newsom there is coming out and he's
actually admitting no
it's kind of our fault sorry yeah we
probably should have managed those
forests huh but we didn't do that very
well
yikes sorry about that and why well one
because he's got to suck up to trump to
get more federal aid
but two because he's looking him in the
face and he knows he can't lie right to
his face
don't forget all these democrats knew
donald trump he would donate to many of
their campaigns
before he ran for president as a
republican and so when they're face to
face with it they have to admit gosh i
hate it it does i know i'm not allowed
to say this on cnn but
you're doing a pretty good job he's
doing a pretty good job that's the
reality of the situation
but is trump going to get the nobel
peace prize uh i don't think so
is the mainstream media going to admit
that trump is doing a good job
i don't think so they've got too much of
a vested interest in
the disorder they've got too much of a
vested interest in
the violence which is a very very bad
thing and it's going
all the way up to the top but much more
important than that
you need to get car parts at a decent
price and that's why you gotta go to
rockauto.com rockauto.com
much much easier than going into the
store you know
i don't know very much about cars i know
this is shocking to you you think that
i'm there
every you know every weekend working on
my car you know getting grease all of
well
no i don't i'll i'll admit that i don't
but thankfully rockauto.com's catalog is
so
simple even i can navigate it and you
know what happens you go to a brick and
mortar store
you say i need this gizmo for my car and
it's the ex and the fx and whatever
and then they say oh yeah we don't have
it in stock but we'll get it in stock
then they go online they probably order
it from rockauto.com
they charge you twice as much don't do
it there's no reason to do that you can
trust rockauto.com their prices are
always reliably low
they're a family business they've been
serving online customers
for 20 years which by my calculations is
basically the entire history
of the internet their family run company
just a
really great reliable guys head on over
right now to rockauto.com
you can see all the parts available for
your car or truck
and then most importantly write knolls
in their how did you hear about us box
so that they know that we sent you
rockauto.com and write
knolls in their energy or about us box
so newsome it admits trump doing a
pretty good job
some people nominating for the nobel
peace prize it meant trump doing a good
job
joe biden not so much while the governor
of california where the wildfires are
raging is saying
that trump is not not responsible for
the wildfires because obviously he's not
joe biden is calling trump a climate
arsonist donald trump warns that
integration is threatening our suburbs
it's ridiculous but you know what is
actually threatening our suburbs
wildfires are burning the suburbs in the
west floods are wiping out suburban
neighborhoods in the midwest
hurricanes are imperiling suburban life
along our coast
if we have four more years of trump's
climate denial
how many suburbs will be burned in
wildfires
how many suburban neighborhoods will
have been flooded out
how many suburbs will have been blown
away
in superstorms
if you give a climate arsonist four more
years in the white house
why would anyone be surprised if we have
more america blaze
if you give a climate denier four more
years in the white house why
would anyone be surprised when more of
america is underwater
trump is destroying the whole world well
what's joe biden's argument here
joe biden who was famously accused by
his own
running mate of supporting segregation
palling around with segregationists
opposing policies for integration
is now accusing donald trump of
supporting segregation
because he thinks suburban communities
ought to be able to write their own
zoning laws
and not have the federal government
steal that power up which they did
during the obama administration
that's the first part of what he's
saying and then because
everybody's making the play for suburban
voters here actually this
obama-biden-era rule this power grab in
the suburbs was all about
turning suburbs which are traditionally
fairly politically
split they're purple districts trying to
flip them
blue so what is his play for the suburbs
why are the suburbs dying why are the
suburbs becoming less pleasant
not because joe biden supported a rising
china
not because joe biden famously supported
shipping jobs overseas
not because joe biden has onerous
regulations and has supported onerous
regulations from the federal government
that's making it much much harder to do
business
no not any of that it's because mean old
trump
is paling around with the sun monster
that's his argument
it's a ridiculous argument and then he
uses that phrase trump is a climate
arsonist
what is a climate arsonist he
he he's because he's not supporting
a government takeover of manufacturing
and industry
and proposing all these huge
redistributive wealth taxes
and not supporting the green new deal 93
trillion dollars
to set up reparations for slavery i
don't know what that has to do with the
environment
because trump's not doing that then he's
responsible for the wildfires which are
being caused by global warming
because science says so except science
doesn't say so and you know who might be
starting the wildfires
not the climate arsonist but the actual
arsonists who are being arrested in
oregon
for setting some of these fires yes
not president trump he's not the one
going around burning down
the the forests some of these fires are
being set
by actual arsonists in ashland oregon
the police chief
tj omira announced on thursday that
there is a criminal
investigation that has been opened into
the cause of the alameda fire
because the circumstances around that
fire are suspicious
here is what the chief said we've got
good reason to believe that there was a
human element to it
we're going to pursue it as a criminal
investigation
until we have reason to believe that it
was otherwise
four people have been arrested so far
this is what the left
does the le it's like that that meme of
that guy
who turns around and shoots somebody and
then he looks to the camera he says why
did you do that
why why did trump do that that's what
the left is doing
the left is committing lots and lots of
violence
the left is projecting everything that
they're doing out and then they're
saying why are you doing that
why why are you doing that in probably
the most discreet violent news there's a
great example of this
there's a guy who was killed by the cops
black man killed by the cops so what
happens
you know you know what happens rioting
in the streets
more riots this time in lancaster
pennsylvania i have images of the amish
just rioting over whatever
the social justice warrior caused du
jour is
the the rioters which include blm and
include antifa are very upset
because a man whose name is
ricardo munoz who's 27 was killed
by the police and because ricardo munoz
is
a man of color i don't know his specific
racial makeup but obviously it's very
very important to the rioters
uh ricardo munoz was killed by the
police it couldn't possibly be a
justified killing so we have riots
except
oh except we have video and it turns out
that before this
this saint this martyr this wonderful
man was shot by the police
he charged at them with a knife you can
see the body camera footage
cops are walking down the street and
then all of a sudden
a guy busts out the door the cops take
off running by the way
the guy is catching up on them with a
knife
wielding a knife in his hand finally
cups turn around and shoot the guy but
what's amazing about the body camera
footage that people aren't really
focusing on
is that the minute the guy comes out the
door the cops don't just start shooting
the cops try to run away and the guy
with the knife
charges at them as they're running away
and then the officers have no choice
but to discharge their weapon so cue
the riots riots going on all over the
place
as always oh justice no peace
blm antifa
[Applause]
shows as clear as day these riots
were never about justice and
conservatives have been kind of dancing
around
this issue they'll always say well you
know the jacob blake shooting
mine it kind of looked like it was sort
of justified well
you know this other shooting or that
other shooting looked like it was kind
of justified well
this fellow doesn't seem to have died
because of police brutality entirely
looks like
might have had something to do with a
fentanyl overdose that he was on and
resisting arrest
but we've all been dancing around it
well maybe it's just a misunderstanding
maybe the left thinks it's an injustice
but actually when you look at the
evidence which no one ever seems that
interested in doing it wasn't an
injustice
stop it stop it these
riots were never about justice
ever get that thought out of your head
tuck it away with santa claus and the
easter bunny
this insurrection that's going on in our
country being led
by black lives matter being
enforced by antifa being encouraged and
promoted by the mainstream media
and elected democrats and appointed
democrats
was never about justice
then why is it that the riots are always
triggered by
the shooting because the shooting is
just the trigger it's like
it's like the church bell in a charming
country town
it's like a rooster crowing in the
morning it's a signal
go out and riot but it doesn't have to
be an unjustified
shooting no one cares about that
they they want to riot the left wants to
encourage
violence they just need a signal to let
them all know okay now is the time that
we go out in the streets and be violent
right you know you don't want just one
or two people going out in the streets
and being violent that's easier to take
down
so there needs to be a signal what's the
signal anytime a cop
of any race shoots a man of color
whatever that means for any reason
whatsoever
if the media can make it sensational
then the left will go out
and become very violent this is
a plan this plan goes all the way to the
top
you don't need to consider this
conspiracy type thinking
listen to the elected and appointed
officials themselves which we will do
but first
we need to listen to one another when we
call one another on the phone but you
shouldn't pay too much for your cell
phone
i know you look at your cell phone bill
you say there's no way this ever changes
there's no way for some reason the bill
gets more and more expensive and they've
got all these kind of hidden fees and
if if you're like me you take a look at
your bill and say gosh this is so much
more money than i should be paying well
what if i told you
that you can save 50 on your cell phone
bill
and not sacrifice any service and by not
sacrificing any service i'm not saying
that there is another you know kind of
cell network or there are these other
cell towers and they're good they're
just as good no i'm saying
let's say you got at t or verizon
puretalk
usa will use the exact same network the
exact same coverage the exact same
towers
but you save 50 how is that it sounds
too good
to be true it's not the average person
is saving 400
a year you can get unlimited talk text
and two gigs of data for just 20
a month they've got a plan that fits
every need and budget
customer service located in the usa
they don't charge you for a whole lot of
data and perks that you'll never use
they don't charge you for the zillion
dollar advertising campaigns and so the
savings goes right to you
unlimited talk unlimited text two gigs
of data for twenty dollars per month all
you need to do is grab your mobile phone
dial pound
250 and say the keyword michael knowles
do that
you will save a ton of money you can
thank me later pound two five zero say
keyword no
skewered michael knowles you gotta say
the whole name otherwise they'll think
you're talking about beyonce
when you do you will say fifty percent
off your first
month this violence
that has nothing to do with justice is
is being organized from the top of the
left
while trump is being nominated for nobel
peace prizes rightly so
the left is openly calling for and
celebrating violence
the city manager of linwood california
jose alma total i don't know how to
pronounce his name and i don't really
care to
uh posted on his uh instagram
a a viral message he's since made his
instagram private this comes from
malcolm x the 1960s radical
leader who said chickens
coming home to roost this is malcolm x
said this
about the killing of jfk so these are
the chickens coming home to roost
because you know
america and white people are really evil
and so it's
totally just that they're now being
assassinated well that's what the city
manager in linwood is saying over the
shooting
of two sheriff's deputies there this is
not some radical activist like malcolm x
i mean i guess he is a radical activist
but he's a city manager and what's a
city manager it's a job that probably
shouldn't even exist a city manager is
an appointed official
who is appointed by an elected official
to do the elected officials job namely
running the city
this goes all the way back to something
we've been talking about for for weeks
on this show
which is the progressive movement going
back to woodrow wilson and even a little
before that
sought to separate politics from
administration
used to be you elect a guy and the guy
runs the government
and then you don't like him you kick him
out and you get some new guy in there
but after the progressive era you have
the separation so
you elect the guy but it doesn't really
matter who you elect
because the administrative state on the
local level and on the national level
is just going to keep humming along and
they're going to keep running your life
for you
and they're not going to be particularly
accountable to politics so that's what a
city manager is
this guy is is the deep state right on a
very local level
this guy is the representative of the
deep state that just goes about and
doesn't really care what you think about
the way he's he's running your lives
and this guy is as radical as they get
he's saying that sheriff's deputies
should be
murdered should be we should just
completely unprovoked
should be shot down in the streets
including a
30-something year old mother a woman
just
shot by this thug because i don't know
because white people are bad or
something or because
america's evil or racist or something
like that that's
how far the radicalism goes
no argument about justice pure vengeance
pure intimidation pure violence
now they obviously don't care about
black lives matter or whatever stupid
saying they're they're talking about
because the city manager
and the left and the media and the
elected democrats they don't talk about
the people being killed in baltimore and
chicago
guess how many people were shot last
week
in baltimore take a guess what do you
say how many people should be shot in
just a week in an american city none
really but let's say one
two fifty fifty people shot in baltimore
over the course of one week from sunday
september 6th
through sunday september 13th
50 shot 15 shot fatally
democrat city nobody cares there's an
overwhelmingly black city
nobody cares nobody cares about black
lives matter chicago guess how many
people were shot
in one weekend not a week a weekend
50 people two days
50 people 11 of them shot fatally
democrat run city overwhelmingly black
none of these people care
the the city manager of linwood doesn't
care joe biden doesn't care the
mainstream media
don't care because
that violence isn't isn't useful to them
so they're not going to exploit it
they're not going to
sensationalize it
conservatives do this thing i think
we're all kind of guilty of it where we
try
to make some rhyme or reason out of what
the left is doing well
maybe the city manager of linwood who's
celebrating the attempted murder of two
sheriff's deputies
maybe he just doesn't understand maybe
he just needs a little bit of a better
art maybe we just need to make better
arguments don't you think
no there's no arguing with this complete
degenerate city manager there's no
arguing
with people who are calling for riots
and violence in the streets there's no
they've they've abandoned argument
they've abandoned reason
they've abandoned logic now we can make
arguments to people
on the right we can make arguments to
the handful of people who are undecided
or to the many people who consider
themselves apolitical and who don't
really pay a ton of attention to these
issues
but there is no arguing with the left
that's encouraging this violence i mean
by definition if you're if you're
calling for insurrection in the streets
you're saying we're going to abandon
reason we're going to abandon logic and
so we should stop wasting our time and
our breath
trying to argue with them we need to
start spending our energy
exercising political power as we can
because the left
is trying to steal this election i was
on the phone with someone yesterday with
a professor friend of mine
who was was asking what do you think is
going to happen with the election do you
think trump is going to win you know i
said
yeah i think he's going to win uh if if
the votes are counted
but i think he's going to lose because i
think they're going to steal it
so it's it's my two answers yeah i think
if the election were held today and the
vote were fair
trump would win overwhelmingly i think
he would win all the states in greenland
okay maybe not that much we haven't
annexed greenland yet unfortunately
but i i think he would win and
significantly
but that's not what we're asking in this
election because the left has already
told us they're not going to play fair
they've already told us
they're not going to concede the
election because this is never about
justice
you know what's going to happen in my
own my own home state of new york
on thanksgiving you always look forward
to it it's it's kind of the
mark the beginning of the christmas
season the thanksgiving day parade
the macy's thanksgiving day parade oh
i've got such wonderful memories
as a little kid waking up sipping hot
cocoa watching the macy's thanksgiving
day parade well it's not going to happen
not going to happen this year for the
first time in the 90-year history
of the macy's thanksgiving day parade
they're not going to hold it because
of coronavirus that's what they say
but it's not about coronavirus and it's
not about public health
bill de blasio back in july when
everyone was worried about the second
wave and coronavirus jumping up again
bill de blasio said yeah we're going to
cancel these gatherings we're going to
cancel
parades or whatever these kind of
similar peaceful gatherings
we're going to cancel in in-room dining
we're going to cancel bars we're going
to cancel concerts we're going to cancel
every
peaceful activity where you can join
together and then he's asked
about the violent riots and the protests
and you know he says
those are okay what about protests if
people want to march down
fifth avenue are they gonna be allowed
to do so look walt this is always an
area of real sensitivity if you're just
talking about
health we would always say hey folks you
know stay home if you can but
we understand at this moment in history
people are talking about the need for
historic changes i mean today
in new york city you know recognizing
the power and the meaning of the message
black lives matter which we did in front
of trump tower today
this is a historic moment of change we
have to respect that but also say to
people
the the kinds of gatherings we're used
to the the parades the fairs
we just can't have that while we're
focusing on health right now
the kinds of gatherings we're used to
you know all the peaceful gatherings
every single one of them we can't have
those
and we can't have those for 15 days
sorry i mean 15 months sorry i mean 15
years sorry i mean no end in sight
we can't ever have those again so long
as we're out of power or i guess they're
in power but
they're not in power at the presidency
they're not in power at the senate
they're only half in power of the
supreme court so sorry we can't have
those
until you give us all the political
power we want we can have violent riots
though and we're going to have a lot
more of them if you don't elect us
that's implicit that's what he's saying
obviously it's not about public health
unless the coronavirus can discern
between
a peaceful parade that you know the
macy's thanksgiving day parade and
violent rioters and mobbers and
marauders in this unless
they can figure out ah okay we're gonna
go it's a republican we're gonna infect
them
oh no it's a democrat hold off virus
hold off fellow viruses
unless it can differentiate that way
then obviously this was never about
public health and de blasio admits it
he says look we got to cancel all the
fun stuff that we all enjoy that's
peaceful and lets us live together
but this is a moment of historic change
what historic change
oh it's a power grab that's what i mean
historic change that's a code word for
a leftist power grab and so we're going
to exploit that
and they're not just doing it in new
york
and they're not just doing it in
left-wing states they're doing it at the
national level
and they are explicitly threatening
conservatives
with more violence explicit
if they don't win the election we'll get
we'll get into those threats because
there's a new one that just came out in
the atlantic
they're all on board with this but first
this october the daily wire god king
jeremy boring
is going to be presenting alongside a
group of incredibly
successful business owners at expert
ownership live
that's another thing that i'm always
slightly interested in because
you know look i think about politics all
the time i think about culture all the
time
i don't think about business quite as
much you know we all kind of think about
business just to
get along make some money but there are
people who focus on business as
their profession as their area of
expertise this conference
features a lineup of speakers including
world-renowned leadership author john
maxwell
the founders of duck commander and
otterbox the benham brothers many others
who can relate to what entrepreneurs and
leaders are going through right now they
will share their stories about their own
businesses and startup journeys
the tough times that come along with all
of those journeys inevitably
and how they were able to come out even
stronger on the other side
obviously we're all thinking about how
to keep our businesses afloat these days
the best part if you go to
expertownershiplive.com knowles right
now you will be able to register
for just 97 and then you can bring a
friend for half off
you do not want to miss jeremy the god
king boring discussing
business go to expert ownership live.com
slash knowles
register for only 97 for a limited time
website address expert ownership live
dot com slash
knowles and then head on over to the
daily wire we will be right back with a
lot more
we are already in a constitutional
crisis and a lot of people
don't know it yet the political
operatives know it
the joe biden campaign knows it even the
republicans
listening to the democratic campaigns
know it but a lot of people don't
understand they say oh well i hope
everything goes well on election day
oh well i hope we can you know resolve
this issue peacefully even though
they're already
rioting murderous democrats around the
country burning down the country
were already in the constitutional
crisis the the election
is already being contested no one's cast
a ballot yet and it's already being
contested
this is a pure power play
joe biden the campaign is now reportedly
expanding its army
of lawyers election lawyers experts in
preparation for the legal battle on
election day
for those who were alive and conscious
during the
2000 presidential election bush v gore
you will remember how many lawyers were
brought in and litigated that thing all
the way up to the supreme court
what we're looking at right now in
november could be
bush v gore times 10 literally times 10
right could be in 10 different states
could be in more than 10 states the same
intensity that was focused on florida
hanging chads how the election
should be counted in florida could be
expanded
to i guess every state in the country
somebody tells me they're not going to
contest
deep red or deep blue maybe they will
maybe they will
joe biden already announced this in july
he announced that he had hired
600 lawyers to contest
the results of the election
and on top of this hillary clinton the
former future president former
democratic nominee for president
came out and said that joe biden should
not concede under any circumstances
so we've got to have a massive legal
operation i know the biden campaign is
working on that
we have to have poll workers and i urge
people who
are able to be a poll worker
we have to have our own uh
teams of people to counter the the
force of intimidation that the
republicans and trump
are going to put outside polling places
this is a big organizational challenge
but at least we know
more about what they're going to do and
you know joe biden should not concede
under any circumstances because
i think this is going to drag out and
eventually i do believe he will win if
we don't give an inch if we steal the
election
joe biden is going to win that's what
she's saying i mean she's saying it as
clearly as you possibly can
and the way she's doing it is the way
the left always does this which is they
say
donald trump is going to inspire
violence so we need to be really violent
donald trump is going to steal the
election
so we need to steal the election donald
trump is not going to concede
so we need to not concede the election
and steal it and hire a bunch of lawyers
they're not saying we need to hire a
bunch of get out the vote
workers saying we need to hire a bunch
of lawyers to steal the election
and yet for all the talk we've heard
about how trump is an authoritarian he's
hitler he's the mango mussolini
he's violent what what violence
has trump kicked off
encouraged condoned celebrated
none none he's given us
peace deals historic peace deals
as i speak they're getting ready to sign
two peace deals
right across the street from me they've
been signing them
we've had a decrease of tensions all
around the world
we've had a drawdown of troops we've had
a drawdown of wars
wars that democrats ginned up
the reality of trump is he's been
peaceful
meanwhile what have democrats been doing
openly
encouraging violence in the streets
we've been told that trump is going to
steal the election
how pray tell is trump going to steal
the election hillary just said there's
they're going to be
intimidating people outside of polling
places give me one example
one example of conservatives
intimidating voters at polling places
you can't
how about how about examples on the
other side well uh
you had the black the black panther
party the the new black panther party
that was actively intimidating people
outside of polling stations in recent
years
media said oh no forget about that don't
look don't look at that video don't look
at those photos that's not real
obviously the democrats are intimidating
people on how to vote right now
they're burning down the country and
killing people over through political
violence and celebrating it
bill de blasio saying yeah that's okay
no peaceful gatherings but violent
gathering is totally cool
totally fine important necessary
historic change
tell me how trump is going to steal the
election no way
no trump has not said i'm not going to
concede under any circumstances the
democrats are the ones
who are saying that and now we have
the the latest threat from the media
from the atlantic you'll remember we
we saw the atlantic on yesterday's show
because the editor-in-chief of the
atlantic
published absolute trash using only
anonymous sources to say that trump
hates the troops
i mean it was it was a childish libel
childish colony
to come out and say yeah trump said that
troops are suckers and they're losers
and they're bad and then
coincide just coincidentally within
hours of the atlantic story coming out
democrats have all of these all of these
campaign commercials ready to go it's
like
you might you might think there could be
some collusion there well now the the
wonderful esteemed atlantic
which i used to read but i used to
actually get the atlantic to my door and
read some of the articles now i like one
writer at the atlantic there's one
halfway decent writer
she's actually a very good writer the
rest complete trash
shady hamid the democrats may not be
able to concede
if trump wins especially after losing
the popular vote the left may draw the
wrong conclusions
this is the era of expecting the worst
while hoping for the merely tolerable
and then they go on to whine about trump
and you know how he's an awful terrible
guy
and then you get to the meat of it in
the second paragraph here's the bottom
line
a loss by joe biden under these
circumstances is the worst case
not because trump will destroy america
he can't but because it is the
outcome most likely to undermine faith
and democracy
is it now resulting in more of the
social
unrest and street battles that cities
including portland oregon and seattle
have seen in recent months by the way
not social unrest
just democrats burning it down and
killing people
and then occasionally a republican who's
being chased down will
will defend himself and then that's
called social unrest both sides doing it
right
very fine people on both sides no it's
democrats committing
all of the unjustified violence
and then the money line for this reason
strictly law and order republicans who
have responded in dismay to scenes of
rioting and looting
have an interest in biden winning even
if they could never bring themselves to
vote for him
you got an interest did you know that
you
you conservative you have an interest in
joe biden winning you know why
because if you don't let joe biden win
we're gonna kill you
that's what he's saying that's what the
atlantic is saying and that's what the
democrats are saying joe biden
threatened it
a little more subtly on twitter or
whatever campaign flack wrote it for him
on twitter
just a few months ago he said we can't
take four more years of this
of all this violence okay it will stop
being violent
stop burning down the city seems easy
enough right oh no
you're not going to stop burning it down
until we give you what you want
and if we don't give you what you want
you're going to
attack our stores steal our stuff burn
down our cities
and maybe even kill us so you got an
interest
i don't think i have an interest in joe
biden winning i don't think i want to
live in a country
where i can be extorted like like
by the mob i don't think that i
have an interest in giving up all
of my political power all of my
constitutional rights
because i'm being threatened by people
and they're threatening my property in
my life i don't think i have an interest
in that
i don't think any of us have an interest
in that that's the threat
that and that's the reality they're
doing it right now we've got to pay very
close attention to the reality i think
this is finally breaking through the
polls by the way
i think the the riots have not played
well in peoria and that's why joe
biden's numbers have gone down
and trump's numbers have gone up and
it's why the democrats
aren't even pretending to be trying to
win this thing fair and square anymore
they're not even they're not even
talking about it
now they're just talking about the
violence now they're just talking about
the lawyers now they're just talking
openly about stealing the election
we're already in this constitutional
crisis okay
and and it doesn't it doesn't matter
what kind of unjust
mayhem the left is causing and it
doesn't even matter what kind of great
wins we're getting from trump
b steals doesn't matter gavin newsom
when he's begging for federal aid has to
kind of admit it
but the the left liberal establishment
doesn't
what's it all about it's because trump
is making changes that actually threaten
the left
you know we talk about squishy
republicans squishy conservatives
conservative but not that kind of
conservative right
and these are guys who play in to the
liberal narrative they play their role
as court jester in the kingdom of
liberalism and they say i wish we could
have gotten more but the culture moves
to the left yeah we've elected some
republicans but
we still get cuties on netflix and the
fundamental redefinition of marriage and
no threats to abortion whatsoever and
now the undermining of
sex itself and a rewriting of what
biological sex means in the civil rights
act and
yeah but look it's just a shame just one
more conservative judge
just one more republican president then
we'll get all the change no
it's a fixed game and then trump comes
in and in a
modest way but a significant way
actually starts to threaten things
actually starts to change things
actually starts to
to change the system of mass migration
which is is
intended to fundamentally change the
country by changing the the people who
vote
and give the democrats a permanent super
majority
so he gets a little win i mean this is
they hated trump for the immigration
issue
immigrate immigration reduction is a
bipartisan issue
the majority of americans want to
dramatically reduce
not just illegal immigration but legal
immigration and they want to reduce it
by huge numbers by 60 percent
this this according to multiple surveys
so why doesn't it get done why do we
only get more and more and more and more
mass migration
because the liberal state has a vested
interest in flooding the country with
people who are going to be much more
likely to vote for them
trump just got a big win on immigration
that's why you need more violence in the
streets that's why you got to steal the
election all the more important
on monday the 9th circuit court of
appeals used to be one of the most
left-wing courts in the country
now it's actually somewhat conservative
thanks to the republican victory
they gave trump a win in a 2-1 ruling
they permitted trump to terminate what's
called the temporary
protectus protected status designations
of sudan nicaragua haiti and el salvador
consider
how far gone our political
self-government
is when you have a program that was
instituted years ago
to give temporary protected status to
certain countries meaning
they can flood the country with mass
migration and then the administration is
not allowed to remove
the temporary protected status temporary
seems to me like its permanent protected
status which we have had effectively in
this country
for the regime of mass migration as just
one example
of how the left is illegitimately trying
to grab power and undermine
self-government
so you vote you go out and vote and you
elect trump and trump says yeah i'm
going to reduce mass migration then he
goes in and he says okay well how do we
do it oh there's this program called the
temporary
mass migration program so i guess we can
just end that because it's temporary
oh no we can't we can't because a court
ruled that he's not allowed to
overturn the temporary program but now
the court of appeals has ruled that he
can
presumably this will be litigated all
the way up to the top
that is the kind of political stakes
that we're at that is
a crisis a constitutional crisis
what happens in november is gonna happen
what's gonna happen is on election night
trump is gonna win i think by a lot
and then the left is gonna say nope
doesn't count gotta gotta wait for those
mail-ins to come in and then they're
gonna go and they're gonna write as many
mail-in ballots as they need
to make sure that trump loses and if for
some reason if by
some fluke that doesn't work
they're just going to keep burning down
the country that's the threat headline
of the atlantic the democrats
may not be able to concede no they can
they're able
they're able to concede but they're not
going to do it
and the leaders of the party are telling
them not to do it
that is a constitutional crisis that is
the the normalization the
professionalization
of political violence meanwhile
president peace prize has just gone over
there
signing one piece deal after another
happening across the street
as we speak what kind of country do you
want to live in
unfortunately it might be too late to
even have a choice we'll keep on
swinging we'll keep on fighting
but but know that we are heading into a
political battle the likes of which we
haven't seen in this country
maybe for over a century on that gleeful
note i'm gonna go enjoy this day
of uh peace deals we're gonna go do a
couple episodes of the verdict podcast
on
this very topic and then i will see you
all tomorrow i'm michael knowles the
michael knowles show
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
assistant director
pavel wadowski editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer robin fenderson hair and
makeup
nika geneva and production assistant
ryan love
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clayton